a bit of breaking news and that's um
regarding uh geronimo you remember the
alpaca who was euthanized this is from
the chief veterinary officer dr
christine middlemas and this is what she
said we've completed the initial
post-mortem examination of geronimo a
number of tb-like lesions were found and
in line with standard practices these
are now undergoing further investigation
these tests include the developing of
bacteriological cultures from tissue
samples which usually takes several
months we would expect to complete the
full post-mortem and culture process by
the end of the year you remember
geronimo testing positive for bovine tb
he was euthanized it was many years of
battle between his owner
and the government and as you can see
now the chief veterinary officer saying
the initial post-mortem has taken place
they did find a number of tb like
lesions and now they're going to
investigate them further and see if what
bacteria they'll find in those lesions
but that's going to take a while several
months and they expect the full
post-mortem and culture process by the
end of the year so that's the latest on
geronimo